hello everyone welcome to the biggest
ideas in the universe I'm your host Sean
Carroll today we're doing the Q&A video
for idea number 9 which is fields
quantum fields in particular if you
remember in that last video what we did
was imagine that we took rather than a
particle like an electron as a point and
therefore you know where it is and
construct a wavefunction which assigned
a complex number the amplitude to every
single location the particle could have
we imagined fields so fields are things
that have values at every location in
space rather than having a location in
space so there's a field configuration
5x some people of course temporary
question here some people always want to
know like what are the fields made of
that has the same answer as my previous
Q&A question about what is the wave
function made the fields aren't made of
anything in the classical field theory
point of view the fields are what the
universe is made of in the quantum field
theory point of view the universe is
still a wave function but that wave
function is constructed from the
classical field configurations so this
would be a classical field configuration
5x you still have a wave function just
as you did in ordinary quantum mechanics
capital psy has a function of Phi of X
and we simplified our lives greatly by
imagining that we had a field that was
free non interacting not doing anything
and then we could actually quantize it
and what we found what I argued anyway
is that in that special case where
there's no interactions where the field
vibrations just pass right through each
other unimpeded but there's only one
field not a bunch of them bumping into
each other then it became clear that the
quantum theory of this field was
equivalent to a theory of super
positions of different numbers of
particles there was a state that look
like zero particles there are states
that look like one particle moving in
different directions so basically the
wave function of one particle is a
little part of the wave function of the
quantum field and there's another part
that looks like wave functions of two
particles and three particles and
arbitrary numbers of particles that's
what we did last time
in future videos we will turn on
interactions and actually let these
fields bump into each other that's
it's gonna lead to particle physics and
all the stuff that you've ever heard
about in the standard model of particle
physics things like that but for this
Q&A video I wanted to actually take the
opportunity to go back and fix some of
the basics I mean I do recognize that
all of these videos are a little more
mathy than maybe you are used to in the
sense that I'm not afraid of writing a
derivative that's fine I think this is
important not to be afraid to write
derivatives it's well it's perfectly
okay to have a popular science
discussion that does not write down
derivatives or do any calculus but there
seems to be a gap in my mind between
that kind of stuff which is very very
good and technical sort of textbook
level stuff which is also very very good
there's a gap in between where you do a
little bit of the math enough to know
what's going on better than you would in
a purely word based discussion but you
don't worry about all the details that
you can solve problems at the back of
the book or anything like that okay
we're just trying to give you a
conceptual understanding so I'm not
apologizing for doing derivatives that's
a good thing but the bad thing is that
we're in a rush to get to the concepts
and therefore we sometimes brush over
important mathematical concepts that I
sort of just take for granted everybody
knows I know better if you ask me does
everyone know this I would say Oh
certainly not but sometimes I make it a
little bit too quick so therefore a very
very basic thing that I want to talk
about is the fact that you know we say
the probability of observing a certain
wave function certain configuration for
the classical wave function sorry the
probability of observing a certain field
configuration of the field certain
configuration of the field is just as an
ordinary quantum mechanics given by the
magnitude or the absolute value or the
norm or whatever want to call it of the
wave function of that particular field
configuration squared okay so the wave
function sigh for any particular thing
that it's going to be a function of
let's say this Phi of X okay for every
possible field configuration v x sy
gives you a complex number okay so
that's a complex number let's write it a
plus IB where I is the square root of -1
and what I want to do is I want to be a
little bit more
precise about why this little notation
of taking the absolute value and then
squaring it gives you the answer we want
okay so this is elementary to some of
you it's completely hocus-pocus to
others hopefully we'll be able to hit a
sweet spot in between so in this formula
I equals a plus IB remember this is just
the wave function at some particular
configuration not the whole wave
function for every field configuration
we have a number called the amplitude
and this is an example of an amplitude
so it's a complex number so a and B are
both real numbers we write them with
this nut script R but sort of a
blackboard are kind of thing blackboard
bold they sometimes call it real numbers
and I is the imaginary unit so it is
really just defined by the fact that I
squared equals minus 1 it's the square
root of minus 1 that's what it is note
to that minus I squared equals minus 1
squared times I squared and that's 1
times minus 1 which is minus 1 so both
minus I and I or in some sense the
square root of minus 1 so what we have
to do is just pick one and we're gonna
we're gonna define this notation square
root of minus 1 to mean I and then minus
I is just minus that ok so we often talk
in this game about the complex plane in
some sense complex numbers are just
combinations of two numbers so this is
let's say a and B right you know are a
plus I B so a is the real part of our
complex number B is the imaginary part
of our complex number and any complex
number is just this sum a plus IB ok so
it's kind of like a little
two-dimensional vector but it has some
extra structure that vectors don't have
namely this eye thing okay I is
something that you can multiply by
itself and you get minus 1 so when we
talked about mathematical spaces as sets
of numbers or set
of objects that have extra structure
this is an example this is a complex
structure on this to real dimensional
space if you wanted to think about that
this is the complex plane when you get
very very very mathy when you think like
a super mathematician you think of the
complex numbers as just numbers
and you talk about the complex plane as
a line because it's just one complex
dimensional rather than two real
dimensional those are equivalent things
personally I'm still in the world of
math where the complex numbers look
two-dimensional to me but it's too real
dimensional which is equivalent to one
complex dimensional okay that's just a
hint of what your life will be like if
you ever become super mathy but the
point is what we can do with complex
numbers is we can find the length of
this triangle right of that little
vector sign I mean you know what that
lengths gotta be just from Pythagoras's
theorem this has got to be the square
root of a squared plus b squared right
that's what it means to have that length
that's a it's a right triangle if you
like well we want to get that in terms
of a formula we just want to remember
the fact you want to be able to write it
down so what we do is we define the
absolute value of a plus IB squared okay
this is the norm squared of this complex
number as the complex conjugate I should
define complex conjugate the complex
conjugate of a plus IB which is often
written physicists write it with a star
or an asterisk as a superscript
mathematicians often write it as a
dagger superscript times a plus IB
itself okay where the complex conjugate
means that I goes to minus I that's all
it means everywhere you have an I it
goes to minus I if you have a complex
number it goes to its complex conjugate
if you have a real number it just stays
the same so complex conjugate sends real
numbers to real numbers and it sends I
to minus I so it sends a plus IB which
is a real number plus I times and times
another real number to a minus IB okay
therefore this complex
number a plus I B has a norm squared
which is a minus I B times a plus I B
and we can work that out
write a squared and then you get a oops
a plus let's see this a hits that and
you get plus I a B then this hits that
and you get minus I a B and then you get
plus minus I times I times P squared
that's this one and that one okay - IB
times IB well clearly these guys cancel
and let's see minus I times I well I
times I is minus 1 minus minus 1 is just
1 so this is a squared plus B squared so
that is indeed the square anyway of that
particular length that particular
triangle like so that's why we will
always get a non-negative number when we
take in this formula for the probability
the wave function absolute value squared
you notice that if we just took the wave
function squared but he just took some
absolute some complex number A plus IB
and squared it you're not going to be
happy at least you're not going to get a
negative number you're gonna get a plus
I B times a plus IB right that's the
number squared which is a squared plus
2i a B plus B squared you go through all
the eyes and that is not necessarily
positive is not even necessarily a real
number right
I appear Xin there it's a complex number
so you can do this you're allowed to
take a complex number and square it but
the equivalent of taking a real number
in squaring it which always gives you a
non negative number in the complex
number is the equivalent taking a real
number and squaring it is taking the
absolute value and then squaring it
that's what we're doing here so that's
why we write those little bars when we
take the square of the wave function to
get a probability
so many many of you probably knew that
many of you probably didn't care but
that is actually what's going on now
that's enough does that's true for all
of quantum mechanics but I want to go
actually into the fields now so the big
thing that we did was argue that you
could think of a classical field in
terms of a sum of a number of modes
right so take a classical field
configuration and then we said it was
particles so that's the short version
let's let's take into a little bit more
classical field configuration we said
that you could always write Phi of X any
function any function
there's probably certain properties of
being well behaved like it doesn't blow
up or have singularities at infinity or
something like that but we're gonna
assume whatever nice behave properties
we need this is another physicist
mathematician trick which is that
mathematicians care most about all the
exceptional cases that you might not
have guessed physicists are like yeah
let's ignore those let's worry about the
generic case let's worry about the
typical cases so we have a well behaved
a nice field Phi and we can write it as
a sum of modes that look like sine waves
with wavelengths lambda height oops the
height is really above zero so I should
do that more carefully get rid of that
there we go
the height is this right H and we have
the wave vector K where they're related
to lambda by lambda equals 2pi divided
by the length of K okay so if you like
you can just write this as a sum over
all possible wave vectors K of some
particular Phi K of H so H is the height
that the amplitude that this particular
mode could have the total contribution
that it is giving to this particular sum
so some modes are just not going to
contribute very much so their height
will be zero other modes will contribute
a lot so their height will be big
and then what we argued is that there's
an energy of each mode Phi K as a
function of its height which is
proportional to its height squared
everything about the mode has an energy
that is proportional to its height
squared and that's what made us think
that we could think about this as a
simple harmonic oscillator simple
harmonic oscillator is a simple quantum
system whose potential energy goes as
its displacement squared so we said I'm
drawing this picture over and over again
we have a wall here there's a spring
okay there's a box this is x equals zero
and this is the displacement X from that
equilibrium position and for something
like this for a box attached to a spring
on a frictionless surface its energy its
potential energy will be proportional to
x squared so what we call a simple
harmonic oscillator I know I'm being
redundant and saying things I've already
said guess what I'm gonna say them again
because these are tricky things so I
like to say them again and again just so
you get them if you're at the point
where you're saying to yourself I know
this already keep going then I will have
succeeded so the simple harmonic
oscillator in general is some quantum
system that let's just call it a
function of X I know we call it a
function of H when we're speaking
specifically about the modes but let's
back up forget that we're talking about
modes of a quantum field and just think
about simple harmonic oscillators I'm
gonna again repeat things that I said in
the last talk the last video but I want
to say them in a slightly different way
so maybe if you didn't completely absorb
them last time you'll get them this time
no problem so here is the potential
energy for a simple harmonic oscillator
one half usually write Omega squared x
squared Omega is just some constant that
tells you what this particular parabola
looks like and it will end up being the
frequency of the oscillator going back
and forth one over how much time it
takes to go back and forth okay and so
the point is that we use oscillator
right the point is that we quantize this
and what
quantizing means in this case is that we
have a wave function Phi of X and we're
going to look for all the possible
solutions to the Schrodinger equation
corresponding to that wave function in
this potential and we're not going to do
this in general what we're going to
notice is that there's a special set of
solutions that are stationary they're
not actually evolving in time themselves
and they have a fixed energy and best of
all we can write all the other solutions
in terms of these solutions and these
were the modes that we talked about okay
the modes or the energy levels for the
simple harmonic oscillator so I've said
all that before what I want to do now is
for to do a little bit better job of
justifying why the specific modes look
the way they do I drew some pictures of
them but let's just try to talk in
another way about why those are the
modes okay so the real answer to this is
undoubtedly you solve the equation
that's that's the answer all right
and anything else is an attempt to
translate that into English so we're
trying to translate it into English but
remember at the end of the day it's not
the English that matters at the end of
the day if you really deeply into your
bones want to understand this you'd have
to pick up the book and look at the
equations you can go to Wikipedia you
know I have mixed feelings about
Wikipedia when it comes to science and
math articles they're horrendously
technical they're very very useful if
you are a research scientist I want to
learn something you wouldn't necessarily
trust what wikipedia says but you could
find the basic ideas and find some
references to things that you might
trust but if you have no idea what's
going on if you're not a professional
physicist or mathematician and you
opened up the Wikipedia page to simple
harmonic oscillator or quantum harmonic
oscillator is particular page it's
nothing but equations but it's
start-to-finish there's not a lot of
intuition given there I don't know why
that is okay so what are we trying to do
well what we might want to do is first
find the lowest energy State this is
we're gonna sort of go step by step here
okay so find lowest energy State
and there's a lot of implicit
assumptions here this is a state of
fixed energy not one that is sum of
different energies but it's a particular
state with the lowest possible energy
okay they're going to build up on top of
that but there are constraints so the
lowest energy state is a wavefunction
okay sigh zero of X let's not let's not
write a vector sign on X it's not a
really vector just a one-dimensional
harmonic oscillator so there is a wave
function which we call sy 0 of X which
would be the wave function of the
oscillator in its lowest energy State
but you might think well where does the
energy come from the energy there's a
kinetic energy that change over time but
we're looking for states that aren't
changing over time we're looking for
states that we can build up other states
that do change over time starting from
them so we're looking for a static site
so there's no kinetic energy there is a
potential energy course that we've drawn
it here v of X the bigger X is the more
the potential energy is and there's also
a gradient energy if the wave function
is changing with respect to space that
costs energy as well the spatial
derivative contributes to the total
energy of the wave function so when we
want to look for minimum energy you want
to minimize the potential energy and the
gradient energy so this already gives
you a whole bunch of information but
it's one more piece of information you
need we know that the wave function has
the property that when you square it to
get the probability so the sum or if
like the integral of the wave function
squared sy 0 of x squared DX this is the
integral under the curve defined by the
magnitude of size squared this had
better equal 1 because this this is the
sum of all the probabilities of all the
different places that thing can be okay
this is a sum of non-negative numbers it
could be 0 but they could be greater
than 0 also and there better be
somewhere that it's greater than 0
because it has to add up to 1 so adding
up to 1 means it can't be 0 everywhere
you might think that would be a very
nice 0 energy field configuration just
let sy be 0
but it doesn't work because we need this
normalization condition as it's called
okay normalization the total amount of
size squared better equal one so you
might guess in other words if you didn't
know about the normalization you might
guess that this is the lowest energy
configuration just a straight line at
zero but that does not work because it's
not normalized okay so we need to do
better well you might think that if you
want to minimize the potential energy
you should get something that looks like
this right something that is very peaked
near zero so it's not getting
contributions from large values of X or
minus X where the potential energy is
large but you notice in order to do that
the gradient up here of sign needs to be
really big okay
so this is going to cost a lot of
gradient energy so you might say going
down this series of bad choices you
might say well this is make it as spread
out as we can so the gradient energy is
very small that is true the gradient
energy would be very small but then out
here and out here you have a huge amount
of potential energy because V is really
big in these places right you're at high
values of X high amounts of potential
energy so see if I can read undo all
those terrible things what you want is a
compromise what you want is a curve that
is mostly concentrated near x equals
zero
but not infinitely concentrated there
because that's too much gradient energy
it has a little bit of spread depending
on the frequency Omega a little bit of
spread to compensate so that you're
minimizing the sum of the potential and
the gradient energies and that's where
you get a curve that looks like this
this is our size zero of X something
that looks like a bell curve a Gaussian
again you can go through the math solve
the equation and get this but that's
where it comes from you're looking for
the minimum energy State okay but now
you're not done yet right you want to
find the next energy next highest energy
well how do you do that you want what
you're looking for is a set of modes
this is one way of doing and not the
usual or only way of doing it
I should say this is not the only nor
even the usual way of doing it but you
want a set of functions with the
property that any wave function can be
written as a sum of these functions
right a weighted sum of these functions
so what you're looking for is another
function psy 1 of X this is the next
highest energy mode and the psy 1 of X
is going to be perpendicular to sy 0 of
X what does that mean that means that if
you integrated them times each other
they would integrate up to 0 so if you
take sy 1 of x times size 0 of X and
integrate that function from minus
infinity to infinity you would get 0 how
is that possible if they're both nonzero
functions well sometimes they're going
to be positive and sometimes they're
gonna be negative so what you want in
sigh 1 is something that also you know
changes as little as possible it's
trying its best to be like sy 0 it wants
to be a very low energy state but it has
to have the property that half the time
it's positive and half the time it's
negative that way the total overlap
between sy 0 and sy 1 will be 0 there'll
be some positive contribution and some
negative contribution and the answer
ends up looking like and ends up looking
like what I drew last time for sy 1
something that goes up crosses 0 and
then goes back to 0 again this is sy 1
of X and so you notice if you look at
the overlap here between sy 1 and size 0
it's a positive amount here and then
it's a negative amount there and you add
up all of them and you get exactly 0 so
in the set in the sense that we can
think of functions as vectors these two
vectors sy 1 and sy 0 are perpendicular
to each other let me remove all those
lines and that's why sy 1 looks like
that it's the lowest energy state that
you can find that is perpendicular to sy
1 and then you keep going and as you
look for more and more functions that
are perpendicular to all of the
functions you've written down
even though you want minimum energy
states you need to give them more and
more energy in order to satisfy the
constraint that their normalization is
one the probability of being anywhere in
that state is equal to one and they're
perpendicular in this sense to the other
ones so what you find is that increasing
modes have increasing numbers of wiggles
okay so this is sy to of X and as
someone pointed out you can count the
number of times that the that the
function crosses the axis crosses the sy
axis right for sy one which is this
yellow one right it crosses at zero
times there are no times that size zero
crosses I might've said sy 0 for sy 0
there are zero times that it crosses the
vertical axis for sy 1 so I want to do
it in green yeah there we go
sy 1 crosses the axis once sy two
crosses the axis 1 2 times and so on and
so you're gonna say is it true that sy n
crosses the axis n times yes it is true
it is also true that sy n has all the
properties of the wave function of n
particles and it's the end highest
energy state so it's like there are n
particles there that is not directly
connected to the number of times the
function crosses the axis but it has
happens to be the same number so it's a
nice easy way of thinking about it ok so
this is the best I can do in trying to
answer the question that was asked in in
the I forget whether it was YouTube or
the blog post or whatever why is it that
the functions that we use as our modes
as our simple harmonic oscillator energy
level functions why do they have their
particular shapes that they do it's
something like this there's other ways
of getting it the word eigenfunction
will appear in your searches if you go
online these are different eigen
functions of the certain of the
hamiltonian operator for the short of
your equation and this simple harmonic
oscillator that's what they really are
but I didn't want to say that out loud
so anyway so that's the point the point
is the combination of things
one is that the classical free fields
can be written as a sum of modes number
two is that the modes individually like
simple harmonic oscillators number three
the simple harmonic oscillators have
discrete energy levels and before the
energy levels when interpreted in the
language of modes of a field look like
states of n particles there you go
that's why quantum field theory gives
you particles at the end of the day in
the next couple videos by the way when
we add in the interactions and let the
fields interact with each other it will
be particles that are interacting with
each other that particle nests will be
taken seriously all of this was to set
things up to be able to say yes fields
act like particles going forward we can
just think about what the particles are
doing that's not always true but it's at
least true in a lot of circumstances
that's why people who do quantum field
theory and tested at experiments are
called particle physicists and why
that's okay all right I think that I
covered what I wanted to do there here's
another thing to do
so sigh oops I don't want to be orange
so I said you know sigh the wavefunction
for any particular field configuration
is a complex number
whereas Phi of X for any particular X is
a real number okay and people were
saying you know well could sy be real
could 5 b complex etc so sigh these are
different kinds of things
okay conceptually very very different
beasts Phi is a classical notion it is
what the field would be in a classical
physics world if you had classical field
theory it is an object that has a value
at every point in space psy is
fundamentally quantum mechanical it
assigns an amplitude to every field
configuration you square that amplitude
to get the probability if you have many
many fields just like the wave function
from any particles was not a separate
set of wave functions the wave function
for many fields is still capital psy of
let's say Phi ADA B you know gee
fada a million different fields okay you
have a million different fields that are
all interacting with each other
all of these are functions of X and they
can all interact with each other in
different ways and that's we're gonna
get to but there's only one sigh is the
point okay there's only one thing that
you call the wave function there's not
many different wave functions for all
the different fields just like with
individual particles but I should so all
this is warm up to say this is a real
scalar field and here the word real word
real does not mean it actually exists it
means that it is assigning a real number
to every point in space there are also
complex scalar field so sometimes the
notation capital v Greek letter capital
Phi is used to denote complex scalar
fields by the way you know this what
I've just written here the little
element sign you have to interpret this
correctly okay in fact let me let me do
it another way just to drive it home let
me get rid of this this is equivalent to
saying sy is a map remember we defined
the space F of all functions of our
three size map from the space of
functions on space to the complex
numbers Phi is a map from space to the
real numbers this capital Phi then would
be a map from space to the complex
numbers completely allowed right you
could do that so you could have complex
valued fields we just haven't been
talking about them yet but they might be
useful for some reason in fact the Higgs
boson is a slightly more complicated
version of a complex valued field now i
mentioning this i don't go into too many
details because we'll build up the
knowledge that we need to talk about
this correctly but i'm not being very
fastidious about staying in
chronological or conceptual or logical
order so i'm giving away some of what's
going to happen i've alluded to
fact that fields not need not be numbers
they need not assign numbers to a
particular point in space they can
assign more complicated geometric
mathematical objects okay so let's
imagine that you have the electric field
there you go the electric field at every
point so the notation on the left-hand
side of the board here means a
particular value of the field at this
point X where as a notation on the
right-hand side says the field over all
of space is a map from space to some
some other space so let's call it V
capital V here is the space of three
dimensional vectors so at every point
the electric field is a little vector
and it's a three dimensional vector in
the sense that it has a component in the
what do you want to call the X direction
the Y direction and the Z direction
just because space is three-dimensional
the vector is also three dimensional but
it's not a vector of space it's its own
independent little vector space called
the space of all possible values the
electric field could have at each point
in real space and we label that capital
V I just made this up I don't know if
this is a common notation for it but
it's a space of all possible
three-dimensional vectors at every point
so e the electric field is a map from
oops that should have been r3 for the
complex scalar field E is a map from
space r3 into the space of vectors okay
and then you can do more complicated
things you could add matrices let's
invent a field capital X little X and
capital X at every point that'll X is a
matrix let's say let's just make it up
it's a five by five matrix so the call
it m5 and we'll do a little blackboard
notation there five by five matrices so
matrix is going to be something that has
it's a little array of numbers 1 2 3 4 5
1 2 3 4 5 1 2 3 4 5 1 2
four or five one two three four five
this is a five by five matrix every
little - I just drew you should imagine
being a number you could have real
valued matrices you have complex valued
matrices you could have vector valued
matrices you could have everything you
see how it's getting very very
complicated so then this capital X is a
map from r3 which is space into the
space of all 5x5 matrices okay it goes
on from there
you can have very complicated
mathematical structures they can be
related in different ways under symmetry
transformations you can ask yourself
what happens when I rotate space can I
rotate the fields inside of each other
without rotating space are there other
transformations can I stretch them and
pull them and so forth this explains why
the fields get grouped into these
particular geometric objects all I want
you to get right now is that we can in
principle have fields made from any
complicated kind of geometric objects
I've mentioned here real numbers complex
numbers vectors and matrices
there are also spinners there are
tensors that there are what are called
differential forms there's a whole bunch
of different sets of mathematical
objects you could imagine you could even
imagine you know a circle you have a
field that takes a value on a circle in
fact this is fun we can do this so let's
call it C of X that's arial 'arial don't
complain I have been paying attention to
her today so C of X is an element of s2
which is a funny way no sorry not s2 s1
so mathematicians call the sets of
spheres SN there's a one dimensional
sphere or two dimensional figure there's
even a zero dimensional sphere so a one
dimensional sphere is just a circle if
you're wondering why aren't circles two
dimensional think about a circle it's
this circular thing it's not the
interior to it or the space that's
embedded in it's just this one
dimensional thing this is s1 the circle
okay so we could easily imagine a field
that at every point in space takes a
value somewhere on the circle you might
parameterize it by the angle call it
theta you
give me a value of theta everywhere in
space with the proviso that theta equals
two pi is the same as theta equals 0 or
theta equals 3 and 60 degrees is the
same state equals zero degrees so this
see that I've just now invented is a map
from r3 to the circle s1 anyway the
point is many different mathematical
structures can give you fields we've
been dealing with the simplest kinds of
fields which are just real numbers
scalar fields real scalar fields which
makes a life very easy so that's one
fact that I wanted to get in to you and
one and that leads very naturally into
something that is again not where it
should be placed in the logical order of
things but you folks have been exposed
to things out there in the world for any
science communicators out there you
should never assume that your audience
is an empty vessel into which you are
pouring your knowledge right real people
have been exposed to things out there in
the world and you have to tell them how
what you're trying to explain relates to
what they've heard elsewhere so here's
something you might have heard elsewhere
if you listen to people who I'm gonna
disagree with you might have heard that
there's something called the Dirac
equation and you might have heard that
the Dirac equation is a relativistic
version of the Schrodinger equation you
might also have heard that there's
something called the klein-gordon
equation and you might have heard that
the klein-gordon equation is a
relativistic version of the Schrodinger
equation neither one of those is true
those are both totally false they it is
true historically that when Dirac and
Klein and Gordon invented their
equations what they were trying to do
was to come up with a relativistic
version of the Schrodinger equation but
they didn't succeed I mean they
succeeded but not at what they were
trying to do they succeeded is something
very different the Dirac equation and
the klein-gordon equation are classical
field equations but just not for wave
functions therefore classical fields
the Dirac equation is the classical
field equation for the electron field
okay it is what is called a spinner
field it is one of those complicated
geometric objects I just mentioned and
Dirac invented it because electrons had
certain properties that the ordinary
Schrodinger equation wasn't quite up to
talking about but when he tried to
replace the Schrodinger equation with
his equation he got all sorts of
troubles and you still read about these
troubles people take them seriously
negative energy states holes in the
Dirac sea and all this nonsense a simple
way of putting it is it didn't work okay
and they patched it up until it kind of
tried to maybe work okay but really what
it was was that the Dirac equation was
describing the classical motion of a
certain kind of field and you should
quantize that field and you do and you
quantize it in the quantum field obeys
the Schrodinger equation but the
Schrodinger equation in its most
glorious abstract form okay we wrote
hours for a [ __ ] equation because we
skipped right to the glorious version so
when we wrote the Schrodinger equation
you wrote in a very abstract form H the
Hamiltonian acting on sy equals I times
the partial derivative with respect to
time of sy so we said if you want to
know how fast the wave function is
changing in time you multiply it by eye
or rep sorry if you want to how fast
that wave function is changing in time
times I the imaginary unit you take the
Hamiltonian and you act it on sy and
this equation works equally well for
nonrelativistic particles for spins for
quantum fields for quantum gravity no
matter what you have this is the
equation of quantum mechanics the
problem is that when you actually ask
what the Hamiltonian is the Hamiltonian
will be different for different kinds of
physical systems ok the Hamiltonian for
a single electron is different than the
Hamiltonian for the electromagnetic
field or for the electron field for that
matter and so when Schrodinger tried
when he wrote this down circa 1926 he
wasn't interested in the most abstract
on sensical version but he
really wanted to solve for what the
electron was doing in a hydrogen atom
okay so that's a situation where the
electron is moving nonrelativistic Li
you don't need to worry about special
relativity the electron has no velocity
close to the speed of light so you can
make an approximation the electron is
Newtonian in some sense and then the
Hamiltonian for the electron in that
particular situation in that particular
context has derivatives with respect to
X
derivatives expect to space of the field
in fact has two derivatives with respect
to space so you have to do respect to
space I'll just write it down d squared
DX squared not gonna go into the details
about this but the point is on one side
of the equation you have to do respect
to X on the other side you have one
River the expected time you know
instantly that this equation cannot be
compatible with relativity right because
relativity treats space and time equally
there's gonna be one derivative respect
to time that better be only one
derivative with respect to space and
vice-versa if there's two derivatives
the same thing so there's an imbalance
here and that makes perfect sense
because Schrodinger was trying to
describe a nonrelativistic electron so
Dirac and Klein in Gordon when they came
up with their equations what they were
trying to do was to modify the
Schrodinger equation to make all the
derivatives match make space and time be
treated on an equal footing and like I
said they came up with equations that
did that but their equations were not
equations for the wave function of a
particle or a field they were classical
field equations which then you take to
define a Hamiltonian okay so basically
the Hamiltonian for the classical field
is a much more complicated intricate
beast than the Hamiltonian for a set of
nonrelativistic particles but if your
Hamiltonian is that of a relativistic
system like the electromagnetic field or
like the Dirac field or the klein-gordon
field then this Schrodinger equation
will tell you how its wave function
evolves so there's a difference between
the field equations for a classical
field and the equation for the
Schrodinger equation which tells you how
the quantum state the quanta
wavefunction of bones so it's even more
complicated than that because there are
limits of very very specific
circumstances in which versions of the
Dirac equation or the klein-gordon
equation can kind of be used like the
Schrodinger equation or can be can be
related to what the Schrodinger equation
says they're very limited and in in
general if you took the Dirac equation
and the klein-gordon equation and
treated them like the Schrodinger
equation you would get bizarre nonsense
you would get negative probabilities and
a whole bunch of things like that you
would get a probability is not conserved
over time so they're clearly inadequate
in general for that purpose but they're
perfectly good classical field equations
that's how you should think of them so
in our point of view in the point of
view I've been indoctrinating you with
the equation for any quantum theory the
equation for the wave function is always
called the Schrodinger equation even if
it's as a generalization of what
Schrodinger himself wrote down in fact I
can be a little bit more specific about
that classical fields you know I thought
about when I did the field video
I thought about spending a whole bunch
of time on classical fields before
quantizing them and I'm like no he's too
much to do in the land of quantum fields
we did a whole video which was over an
hour long we didn't even get to
interactions at all there's going to be
two more videos coming up just to get
interactions correct okay so and even
then there's gonna be a lot that we be
bound so anyway I didn't do a lot of
classical fields so let me do just a
little tiny bit more on classical fields
to drive home the similarity the fact
that a classical field is a classical
physical system not a quantum system so
classical fields you know Phi of X and
also of T right if it's evolving in time
well this is the configuration of a
classical field okay we called it that
before many times and compare that to
classical particles when we had
particles we did the Newtonian thing we
said that Isaac Newton would have said
you have a position that changes over
time and from that you can derive the
plot
city in the acceleration that's how
Newton talks about the change of a
particles trajectory over time this is
the Newtonian version but there was also
the Hamiltonian version so or you could
talk about the pair X and P at any one
time this is the Hamiltonian way of
thinking about things the difference
being that in the Newtonian version you
define the velocity to be the derivative
of the position over time and treat that
as part of your theory as a fundamental
thing so in order to make sense of what
the theory says you can't simply work at
one moment of time you have to know
something about how the thing is
changing over time whereas in the
Hamiltonian version you have position
and momentum as separate independent
variables okay when you define your
space of all possible States you give me
the position or the configuration if you
like and then you give me the momentum
and then the fact that the momentum is
related to the velocity the fact that
the velocity is the velocity V is
momentum divided by the mass this is an
equation of motion this turns out to be
true on real-world trajectories for
fields but it's not the definition of
anything that's the conceptual
difference between the Newtonian and the
Hamiltonian way of doing things so you
might want to say well is there a
classical field version of the momentum
is there a Hamiltonian way of thinking
about classical fields yes of course
there is what are you talking about so
you can also have field momentum and we
often call this PI of X and T so we have
the set Phi of X M PI of X being your
classical field configuration and your
classical field momentum and guess what
there will be a relationship between pi
momentum of the field and the time
derivative of the field and that
relationship
is again an equation of motion in the
Hamiltonian way of doing things so this
is something that you know even the best
professional not the best but even
really really good professional
physicists sometimes they're sloppy
about you can think about a field
changing over time and take its
derivative over time talk about five dot
sometimes we write this as Phi dot of X
just a convenient notation for the time
derivative of Phi put a dot over it okay
if you want to take the second time
derivative you put two dots etc and
that's how fast the field is changing
over time in the Hamiltonian way of
thinking there's a separate thing called
the momentum field the momentum of this
field the momentum configuration if you
want there's a really no good word for
it the conjugate momentum to the field
configuration PI of X and then you
derive an equation of motion relating PI
of X to the time derivative of Phi but
you do one or the other okay you don't
do both you got to choose which language
you're using are you thinking Newtonian
in which case you have five X 5.25
double dot etc or are you thinking
Hamiltonian in which case you have Phi
of X and PI of X and they interact and
relate to the equations of motion in
different ways so I'm not going to go
through all the mathematical details
there but if you wanted to know is there
a classical field theory analog of the
momentum then the answer is yes and here
it is you don't see it as often but it's
definitely there and you do see it
sometimes okay final thing one more
topic I wanted to talk about and
actually this is again something I
thought about putting in into the
original video but just didn't quite fit
entanglement I mean we had the entire
previous video about entanglement and
how important it was to quantum
mechanics and then we our first field
Theory video and didn't talk about
entanglement much at all we should talk
about a little bit so here is space okay
and because we did free fields we
instantly did the following thing we
wrote our arbitrary field v acts as a
sum of modes Phi K
with different heights H okay and K is
the weight vector pointing in different
directions which tells us the wavelength
and that's okay we can absolutely do
that we did do it it was very very
useful but notice that these modes go
all over space okay here's a particular
5k they stretch all throughout the
universe there is no place where the
field with the mode does not have a
value okay
it is not localized so it's sort of the
opposite of 5x which is telling you the
value of one point in space 5k is
telling you a certain amplitude for that
frequency that wavelength over all of
space so it's kind of the compliment
it's kind of dual in some sense but we'd
have to do that we could have stuck with
5x we could've just given you the value
of Phi at every point in space
it's just that then you don't get this
beautiful structure where everything
looks like a harmonic oscillator so a
quantum field is not a harmonic
oscillator at every point in space
it's a harmonic oscillator for every
mode for every wave vector but that mode
is a plane wave that stretches all
throughout space okay however like I
just said we don't have to use those
modes we can choose to describe our
quantum field in all sorts of ways 5x is
a different way here's yet another way
imagine that maybe we'll use a different
color for this I don't know if it's
gonna help or not but imagine that we
divide space into regions okay I'm only
drawing two dimensions of space but you
know there's really three dimensions
there so we have different regions of
space and inside every region I can do
this exact same thing I can talk about
the modes of the field inside a region
right so inside any region I can talk
about you know the long wavelength modes
the short wavelength modes etc and then
I can talk about how to build up the
field as a whole from what it's doing in
every region classically that makes
perfect sense classically I can just do
this okay quantum mechanically I can do
that too but it's way harder why well
because this mode decomposition where
you have the modes stretching throughout
all over space is very natural and easy
and you get simple harmonic oscillators
once you top up the field into values of
different locations in space
you no longer have simple harmonic
oscillators all the modes are
interacting with all the other modes
it's no longer this simple free field
set of different some of things that we
can solve individually perfectly well
but you can do it you're allowed to do
it why would you want to do it you may
ask well in this sum of modes for the
free field every mode of the field was
independent of every other mode
there was no relations ever I thought
that is what the word free meant that
the individual modes didn't interact
with each other in this decomposition
they do interact with each other and
therefore guess what in the way the
function in big sigh whatever that is
let's just take the ground state wave
function as we call it the lowest energy
wave function so let's imagine a
universe without any particles in it
okay let's imagine a quantum field that
is in this lowest energy state okay
the vacuum call it size zero and it's
called the vacuum this is the thing that
we calculated the energy of and said
that naively we get an infinite quantum
mechanical contribution to the energy by
the way someone asked why isn't it this
famous number ten to one hundred twenty
or ten one hundred twenty two you'll
find out soon I don't think you're gonna
find out in the next video but in video
number eleven maybe you will find out it
at the level that we did it in the last
video it was correct to say that the
correction is simply infinite because
there was no gravity there was no pong
scale or anything like that it was just
quantum field theory all the way down
anyway vacuum vacuum state vacuum wave
function for quantum mechanical field
has a certain property you can express
the field itself in any variables you
want
here we've chunked up the field into
what it's doing in different pieces of
space different parts of space and what
we will learn if we did this we're not
gonna do it in any detail but we learn
is that the field values in different
regions are entangled with each other I
mean you could have guessed that write
the word entanglement is right there
this is what we're talking about if you
choose to express the quantum field as
the quantum wave function as a function
of the field itself being expressed as
what it's doing in different locations
in space
unlike the plain waves that stretch all
throughout space the localized parts of
the field become entangled with each
other they need to be entangled so that
the wave function as a whole represents
the vacuum represents the lowest energy
State so there is entanglement you write
this down modes I'm gonna put this in
quotes because these are like these
little mini modes modes confined to one
little location of space in different
regions are entangled and an extra
little fact the entanglement fades away
as you get further away so as you go to
further and further regions of space
there is still entanglement but there's
less and less okay so what's going on in
this region let me just color it in this
is the region that we're paying
attention to this region is entangled at
least a little bit with every other
region of space all throughout the
universe ok that is a feature of the
vacuum of quantum field theory modes in
I will put it in all different regions
of space are entangled with each other
ok there's a little bit of entanglement
there's there's an amount of
entanglement which is large for nearby
regions and it gets less and less as the
regions get farther away so we could
actually plot this if you want to plot
distance between the regions versus
amount of entanglement it's not that
hard to guess but it goes like this ok
as the distance increases the
entanglement goes down that's kind of
natural I mean they're next to each
other right if the regions are right
next to each other sort of bumping into
each other then they're gonna become
entangled in the lowest energy State
once they all settle down there's a
little bit of entanglement with your
neighbor a little bit of a tangle move
with the 1 further off a little bit less
with the 1 further off than that but it
never goes to 0 there's always a little
bit of entanglement so this is part of
the idea that the quantum field theory
vacuum is kind of an exciting place that
has kind of
a lot going on we made it seem very
simple by jumping right to this
description where we talked about plane
waves filling all of space that's the
description in which things seem very
simple so it's an obvious one to use but
if you want to look at what the field is
doing in different regions region by
region there's a complicated
relationship between what's going on in
those different relations and they are
entangled with each other and that leads
to a fun fact I have to tell you this
fun fact I'm not sure whether this fun
fact will be at all understandable or
believable but you know you got to give
a little reward for following this this
far the fun fact is called the re I'm
not sure I'm pronouncing it correctly
riche leader theorem letting strata
state the theorem in the language that
we've been using here but let me say it
in words then I'll try to write it down
the theorem says this do something to
the field in one little region of space
for this little green region that we've
highlighted here okay so I have the
quantum field in this vacuum everywhere
it's in the lowest energy State there's
no particles around or anything like
that
I'm localized to a little tiny region
myself or it could be a big region but a
region this is one of those things with
infinity there's an infinite number of
modes in quantum field theory in any
finite sized region so it doesn't matter
whether it's a small region or big
region there's still an infinite number
of modes and those modes are entangled
with another infinite number of modes
elsewhere in space and the reef slider
theorem says there is something I can do
or imagine doing has put it that way
some quantum mechanical operation I can
do purely localized to one region with
the feature that afterward I've changed
the quantum state it was the vacuum mode
it was the vacuum state for the entire
quantum field I've changed it in one
region and by doing that I can make the
global quantum field look like anything
at all look like any state whatsoever
okay and I'm again this is one of those
times when the experts are going to be
like cringing a little bit because
there's there's technicalities here you
have to worry about but I'm trying to
state the theorem in the language that
we can understand that as accurately as
possible
by operating on let's split that way by
operating on the vacuum waves the wet
vacuum wave function the vacuum state
size zero in one region we can convert
from size 0 to sy star where size star
is any state of the quantum field
so one technicality is it's not actually
any state it is arbitrarily close to any
state you know you give me a state you
want me to create I can get literally
arbitrarily close to it so for all
intents and purposes I can get to any
state this sounds like it's amazing and
it is amazing all of the work is being
done by two facts one is the
entanglement what the field is doing in
one region of space its entangled with
everywhere else and number two this word
operating on so this is a more general
feature than measuring okay I'm
manipulating the field in one region of
space and because it is entangled with
the entire rest of the universe I can by
manipulating the field here turn the
state in the rest of the universe to
anything I want so this has been called
by some people the Taj Mahal theorem
because by doing something here to the
quantum state of the universe in my
office I can create the Taj Mahal on the
moon that is one of the states of the
quantum field if I could imagine
creating and you're like well what about
energy conservation all that stuff it's
not Energy's not conserved in this case
because you're doing things to the
quantum field the quantum field is a
superposition of modes with a whole
bunch of different energies it's the
right superposition to be the lowest
energy after overall but I'm picking out
different particular parts of that
wavefunction and they could have
arbitrarily large energies so let me try
to justify this hand wavy argument just
think about think about entanglement to
think about Alice and Bob think about
Alice and Bob in their spins right so
think about the state that we wrote as
one over the square root of two times
Alice's spin is up
Bob's is down plus Alice's spin is down
Bob's his up okay now what we said was
you could observe Alice's spin she could
get spin up or she could get spin down
you don't know which and by doing it
Bob's will be the other one if Alice got
up Bob will get down and vice-versa
so the problem there is Alice can't
force the answer up or force the answer
down when she measures her spin she will
get up or down with 50-50 chance so
that's why this word operating is more
general than the word observed observed
means a specific kind of operation where
you entangle remember you get
decoherence and all that stuff but here
we're allowing Alice the freedom to say
I'm going to force my spin to be up I'm
going to force my wavefunction to just
be up okay so by doing that so Alice
forces her spin to be up then what do we
know we know that Bob's is instantly
down right just from the structure of
this wave function even if it's very
very far away and if she can force her
spend to be down Alice's Bob's will be
up if he if sorry if Alice forces her
spin to be spin right along the X
direction then Bob's will be spin left
etc so in this entangled state if we
magically because it's more than just a
simple measurement but if we magically
give Alice the ability to do anything
she wants to her qubit to her spin we
can make Bob's spin be anything we want
right we can just create that happening
so that is what's going on in field
theory all throughout space there's an
infinite amount of stuff going on in
every region of space in quantum field
theory and so I can do things to the
field in this region right here
like if I can force it to in this region
being
specific field configuration then I can
make these other regions do whatever I
want because they are entangled and by
manipulating that state in this part of
the of the universe exactly right I
could in principle create anything I
want elsewhere in the universe
now there's two caveats here one is I
can't physically do it right like I said
Alice can't just force first Bend to be
up it's in a superposition and she
doesn't know what she's gonna get when
she measures it number two even if we
let her do this we're now promoting from
this simple case where you have two
qubits to a case where both Alice and
Bob have an infinite number of quantum
modes and there are an infinite number
of Bob's okay
so we're taking advantage of the fact
that infinity divided by infinity can be
equal to 1 or can be equal to zero
depending on how you do it it can be any
number of different numbers infinity is
a tough thing so the reach leader
theorem takes advantage of the infinity
nosov infinity in a very fundamental way
what you should get out of this is not
some technological ability that we have
to create new things or Taj Mahal's on
the moon just by manipulating quantum
fields here in your room what you should
get from it is an appreciation of the
fact that every quantum field has an
infinite number of degrees of freedom
even in a little tiny region of space
and all those degrees of freedom are
entangled with each other if you divide
up the field into what's going on in
different regions you have an infant
amount of entanglement everywhere this
is a hint
you know and so they put this way
quantum field theory is hard I totally
recognized that the last video was a
challenging one ok but we really
simplified it by a lot by looking only
at three quantum fields and by cleverly
doing instantly the smart thing of
looking them in terms of modes and
analyzing the modes one by one we made
quantum field theory looks a lot simpler
than it really is
in the real world it's very easy to
start asking questions about quantum
field theory where the answers are
surprising or impossible to find it's
just too difficult to ask exactly
because of this infinity of stuff going
on everywhere so that's why quantum
field theory in a very real sense
continues to be a challenge to this day
there's a whole subfield of
it's called algebraic quantum field
theory or axiomatic quantum field theory
and it's separate from particle physics
like particle physicists use quantum
field theory is incredibly successful
Higgs boson got predicted many other
things got predicted and so forth but
they're sloppy about the math okay
they assume certain integrals give
finite answers etc etc etc there's this
whole sub field called axiomatic quantum
field theory where you try to prove
things with mathematical rigor and as
impressive as it is what's been done and
the amazing amount of progress has been
made it turns out to be really hard to
prove anything and not much that we
would like to prove has been proven in
fact they're a bunch of theorems that
have been proven they kind of say you
can't ever prove the kind of thing you
want to prove it's very difficult to
make a fully realistic interacting
quantum field theory at all so quantum
field theory is hard and that might be
because nature is hard because our puny
human minds are had difficulty wrapping
themselves around it or it might be
because quantum field theory is not the
right answer they may be all these
efforts to make quantum field theory
completely rigorous are kind of barking
up the wrong tree to be like you know
making Kepler's celestial sphere is
completely rigorous maybe a fun math
problem that doesn't relate to the real
world we don't know but we're going to
be exploring things like that in the
videos to come